hello hey what's up party people
someday I'm going to address you as
party people and sing all of them there
it is by tag team mm-hmm
today is not that day Jo Dan lon yep
we're talking all of the timber that's
higher filmography of Tim Burton one at
a time so let's start peeling well
Frankenweenie enjoy
that's the shorts well guys let's all
just talk and very clippable sound bites
Tim Burton cancelled no that's not in my
house
is he supposed to be canceled no no I
was joking before the show that it would
be funny to all pretend that Tim Burton
was canceled there's some horrible thing
that we're not gonna mention I mean I
should be very serious but it's not true
Tim Burton a lovely man apparently so I
haven't heard anything horrible
allegedly so Dumbo's coming out yes
that's why we did this
yeah because we do whatever tenuous
connection to something that we can to
justify doing a trailer sometimes the
original jumbo movie what do you really
say it's it's it's less than an hour
long yeah it's very short race is
questionable at best in places and were
you gonna hang your hat yeah we did that
we did that we did the Disney's weird
pass thing which on the road to my book
and we don't want to do it all over
again Dumbo is really I feel like the
pink elephants on parade sequence taken
on such a larger cultural significance
than anything else in the rest of that
movie yeah it's kind of like the whole
movie exists just remind that a racist
birds that's all yeah it's only come in
at the end yeah it's like 50 minutes
long it's it's it's it's barely a
feature which in hindsight if we had
figured out a take would have been much
easier feature like simple easy
that would have been much easier guys
make sure you send him some love online
did Dan took the brunt of this one yes
when assignments were being given out it
was like okay Wanda Danielle why don't
you work on Aquaman and I'm going to
work on spider Stan some eyes on all
these Tim Burton day me like watching
lots of things and hate to say no yes I
watched all 18 features watch 10 during
the time I think about nine or ten
during the time we were making this
trailer but certainly not only there
were solving that were as bad as I
remembered or worse yep movies like
Planet of the Apes and Alice in
Wonderland and I'm very happy I'll never
have to watch again I think Alice and
dark shadows are by far the two bottom
see I actually maybe because this was
the way it was set up for me I did not
mind dark shadows it wasn't great but I
laughed it was like the abomination you
were expecting no I I didn't think it
was a terrible movie maybe just me I
don't I do not care for that dark chef
very well it just it just feels like
it's in the middle of being four
different movie like if there's 40
movies out here that could have worked
and it's right in here like trying to be
all of them at want to center square
doesn't just doesn't it's not funny it's
not scary it's like what is it I don't
know I did not watch The Nightmare
Before Christmas because we discussed it
and it is not a directed film by Tim
Burton so that was not included we the
reference that in the trailer because we
knew that was the first thing that
people would mention it's sort of a
Garth merengue where it's like think of
Tim Burton they think of that memory for
granted we didn't do it that because
then it was like well because if we do
if we do Knight River Cruises and then
we have to do Hoffa and all the other
thing we see produced where do you draw
the line so we just did the name the
little tip of the hat to Jack Skelly
Shore trailer
plus they're ahead eighteen I couldn't
really do many more well big picture
yeah how do you feel about timber I mean
everybody and everybody knows
is a certain thing that danny elfman and
the Gothic style but there were small
things that you start noticing when you
watch them all together like there's one
thing that's not in the trailer that was
originally the trailer but just the
characters watching television and then
you look at a bunch of interviews I
watched a lot of interviews and he talks
about being brought up largely in front
of a television as a babysitter the
suburbia and the you know and and the
fact that all of his characters are and
he didn't even write all these scripts
but he seems to run towards stories
about outcasts and then that was very
much how he grew up he grew up is like
this kind of he talks about you people
get categorized early and you're weird
if you're into certain things and you so
much so many of those themes just feed
into his film yeah we talked about one
other thing that going back now and
watching some of the movies after
thinking about this it's remarkable is
that he loved Frankenstein as a kid yes
and if you just all you think about is
that story it informs so much there's
like bringing people back dad making
people and people right being stitched
up and sort of half complete and hybrids
of all these things together and like
you know he's he's creepy meets that
little girl and there's that creepy
scene where at first they play and it's
sort of innocent and then it turns
really dark and the castle up on the
hill with the villagers living all below
and it's like so much of those visuals
in his movies we talk about the elites
which we'll talk about the trailer and
and weird things like hand his hands he
likes hands like just had traction yeah
elaborate you know like the opening of
peewee is what I always think of where
he's got the crazy breakfast machine the
one thing that couldn't make it into the
trailer I couldn't find a place for it
but is that every single movie is fish
mm-hmm and I don't know what it is about
him and fish I tried to find something
about him talking about fish or why he
likes fish I mean obviously beyond big
fish but but every Tim Burton every
single one you're gonna find something
with fish fish tanks or fish heads or
someone's in the fish business or some
horrifies talking
it's these weird things it's the things
that you know about Tim Burton but then
it's things that are either you can tell
he identifies with because if that's how
he grew up or just weird stuff that
you're like I don't even know what to do
with this yeah you talked a lot about uh
you talk a little bit about like being
like left in front of the TV as a kid
but how does another thing came up is
like parents who don't really care about
you right
parents who ignore their kids or who's
really indifferent to their kids is such
a crazy prevalent theme in all of these
you really see how you know people talk
about Kubrick and Hitchcock and how they
brought their methodologies and
psychologies into the making of a film
and it's very obvious from watching
their films that that's the case but
it's not something you would think about
necessarily beyond just a style with Tim
Burton but when you watch his movies
altogether you're a star you know some
patterns see yeah you see him in those
movies especially the ones like
Frankenweenie and the ones that are like
his babies yeah he brings I mean it's
just so much about the outcast of weird
kids the the bringing the animal the
this thing about the animals and death
and the dark haired kid who soft-spoken
with like big eyes he feels very
isolated and a little weird and you know
like he's kind of darker and less
confident than everyone around him like
that obviously mirrors something Tim
Burton feels he himself is strange and
unusual and just very tactile models and
claymation and things you make with your
hands and he talks yeah fact that he
likes that he doesn't like green screen
he likes sets and it's just it's it's
it's it's some filmmakers you watch the
filmography and you're like they have a
style but you don't really see them in
it as much it's it's much more just the
very stylistic touches and there's some
personal stories there's some that
really aren't right Spielberg is one
there's some Spielberg movies he has a
style and there's so see what movies
that are super personal and then there's
some that are just big Steven Spielberg
right like he'll make an et where it's
like obviously speaks to things that
Spielberg felt growing up about being a
kid of divorce sort of a girl with
siblings where but then there are also
ready player ones where
like he just took this script and made
it you watching a Tim Burton movie no
matter what genre it's and you see
something that is like him that is him
that is personal that is his past and
that's I didn't expect that going in I
thought it'd be like how trees and
stitches and whatever of the the trailer
trees and stitches oh yeah it's kind of
an interesting journey shall we watch it
yeah I just realized that all of our
headphones are on the floor oh no okay
so I'm just gonna ban for a minute while
the guys just sort of like get on the
ground and look for their headphones we
really should have done this before we
started shooting but sometimes we just
don't think about think mondays are
usually thank you pretty busy okay
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory is a
great example of he's taking somebody
else's material yes but he still puts
all this stuff in there it's like back
to dad who doesn't care of his kid teeth
all that dad stuff you asked if early
and the teeth and the dentists it's it's
it becomes super Burton even though it's
this story we all know in the worst way
possible it's in freakin Burton Tim
freaking Burton that's what I Colin from
director Tim Burton who never met a
studio title card he couldn't darken
okay this one didn't need much help that
spends four different decades multiple
genres and ten thousand pounds of white
pancake makeup every Tim Burton movie
get Robert for that that looks so great
could the say one wanted to do something
sorry Robert Robert Holtby is amazing he
did our graphics and it gave him some
directions about try this try that and a
like he did what he does which is
incredible he's just like yeah I just
said you I'd stood them all yep so I
think we have them so that everyone can
I guess yeah we did use all but Robert
being amazing as always and going above
and beyond the call of duty
amazing work - Beetlejuice right there
yeah put on your best right suit and
enter the mystical world of Tim Burton
first entirely of the suburbs a lonely
house sitting on a hill or a lonely
house on a hill overlooking the suburbs
and meet a Tim Burton protagonist a pale
loner cast out by society and or their
family looking for acceptance and or
revenge watch as they relive their
tragic past through flashbacks
many very sad flashbacks cabinets and
Burton films thinking about pasts I'm
sorry I was having a flashback we see
wash backs happen often increasingly
attend fancy parties share the screen
with a horror icon or an actor playing
alright guys buzz there were actually a
bunch of horror icons that are in them
that were we just weren't they were
famous enough to put in well they're not
the actual character Elvira
but Vampira Vampira and the actress who
was later Elvira both in Tim Burton
films but yeah it's like Michael Gao was
in a ton of those old like hammerheart
Alfred and he's also in Sleepy Hollow
there's just like a bunch of examples of
that we just picked the most famous is
Christopher Lee Vincent Price yes yeah
and then Bela go yeah so we don't have
the real estate for some of these B and
C stirs but once I sort of keyed into
that started looking it up I realized
like almost every Tim Burton movie has
at least one person who you would
consider like a kind of an old-school
horror guy had a good time back into
that the reason why is that that's what
he was watching right as a kid on
television and their parents was looking
for the television he would watch the
Vincent Price movies and Christopher Lee
movies and and these old creatures and
then he would just go on to make movies
either about these people or with these
people even if it's a we a movie like
Charlie and some of the factories it has
any connection to that whatsoever that's
the kind of stuff that you can which has
got to be cool the day that like you're
shooting Edward Scissorhands and price
shows up to shoot his scenes like that's
gotta be a pretty rad is really cool the
way he sort of uses a lot of the
language of those old movies to create
you know new dice I watched Sleepy
Hollow for this not that long ago and
the way that they sort of visually like
they're using new what was in the year
1999-2000 very state of the art
techniques and color shading and all
these elaborate sets to really make you
feel like yeah you're watching a movie
from the 60s like an old British Hammer
horror film and it's it's really cool
how he can sort of do that like take
today's technology to bring these old
styles kind of back to life yeah second
favorite Burton film Sleepy Hollow let's
go I love that we fall in love with an
ethereal blonde blondes or some
yeah he's got birds yeah oh you
definitely got a thing with over-clean
bird yes he was a wonderful grandpa but
not such a great dad you know after that
night I didn't speak to my father again
for three years
no parents deserve to boil and hell's
ever lost some fire
oh well dealing with an antagonist
that's probably wealthy overweight or
both you'll be sorry pee-wee Herman
geez what a fat rich people do to this
guy and pawn yeah another one regardless
of genre mm-hmm the often so often the
antagonist of the film is the elite or
the concept Batman Returns the whole
plot is about revenge on the elites and
the firstborn sons of Gotham the the the
Sleepy Hollow
the plot is from the town's elite from
the judge in the mayor of the town the
the Frankenweenie the mayor of the town
is the guy he's the elite it's this idea
of like the people in power the people
are not to be trusted they're either
evil they're he's very good using a
visual shorthand to to just make you
immediately go okay I know what I'm
supposed to feel about this person so
you know with the they're either fat or
rich or both have a weird it is a
spectrum of the leaner and more gone and
pale you are the the better and the
fatter and more like vivid the worse and
I mean like you can really see I know
Nightmare Before Christmas he came out
of the story didn't produce but it's so
clear in Jack Skellington rail fin he's
the hero and the mayor two-faced he's
the villain and he's huge basically a
soil and it's different sorts of elite
depending on the movie like in Gotham
it's this high society but in
Beetlejuice it's yuppies it's these
people that come in and destroy the old
ways and and want to get rid of
everything she's actually fascinating
like it's way before Americans were
really keyed into gentrification is a
huge problem but that is what it's about
it these rich people from the city
coming in and they're gonna ruin winter
river with all of their money the
interesting thing about it and I started
think about this more Maggie may fish on
film Twitter had a great Tim Burton
essay
because she hadn't really watched any
Tim Burton Ford and crank through a
bunch of them and the interesting thing
to me about that is that even though it
is about gentrification these yuppies
coming in and wrecking everything at the
end of the day the peaceful resolution
is gentrification well Vidia sort of
like putting on the leather jacket it's
a hybrid though because if you look the
house is restored to its farm house yeah
look and Lydia is high school but she's
the foster pet that the ghosts are now
her parents really yeah it's a little
bit about the the deeds have to sort of
come in and become part of the community
they can't keep their New York lifestyle
in winter they have to become right
locals Maritza's mixture it's it's this
formation of a new which is I mean a lot
of what that movie comes down to it's
about like sort of acceptance rather
than don't fight it accept your
situation because that's the problem
that Geena Davis mouths bald and at
first they're like we don't want to be
dead we got to get out of this and then
eventually it's like it's kind of the
same as Edward Scissorhands - that sort
of don't fight it except what you're
right
your cards are icy hose because you know
that ends with Edwards like well going
back up to my creepy house it's it's
it's you can almost track his state of
mind tell he'll tell you the movies
where he was like in a dark place like
Mars Attacks where everything is just
the people that you think should live
don't live and the people that it's very
cynical and he'll say like yeah I was in
a real dark place when I made that movie
I was in a very cynical you can see that
I mean even between Beetlejuice and
Edward Scissorhands like Beetlejuice is
about like these new things this new
world and the inclusion of it and then
Edward Scissorhands which is after
Batman this huge mega blockbuster is
sort of about retreating back to your
little cloistered thing and still being
a pretty I mean it's just like the
psychology there it's fascinating
yeah yeah yeah well and even with with
Edward Scissorhands there's a lot of you
you can talking about seeing Burton and
his characters you know you have this
guy and all of a sudden he's on the
world stage he's famous you just did
Batman and if you sort of apply that to
Edward the
you have the suburbs just turn on him
you know come on a dime this like new
shiny toy and and I think it's telling
that he the second he had the resources
to do really whatever he wanted to do he
did that a much smaller movie about this
acceptance of this loner but but the
world didn't it's you could do you could
write it I'm sure people have you could
read books oh yes yes yes there's a lot
like it's these movies very
psychologically rich yes because we even
talk about like one of the other things
that we were talking about when we were
making this trailer is bi like bullying
and jealousy and even like sexual
jealousy that also runs through
literally all of these movies there's
always an angle of like somebody being
sort of sexually jealous of somebody
else is this leading to all of these
conflicts and Edward Scissorhands you
know there's like the boyfriend yeah
that's rich by the way yeah it's just
it's so on his mind it just keeps the
same kind of ideas keep recurring
through all of the movies yeah
fascinating but it is it's yeah
let's keep going Hey journey into the
mind of a director who's constantly
journeying into his own mind can we do
some kind of fella gotta go find figure
out where this comes from
try as he uses tens of millions of
studio dollars to exercise his childhood
demons how strange were you was a child
from traumatizing memories nobody seemed
to really like me
two childhood fears I remember certain
clowns dislike certain quality to the
least surprising fact about Tim Burton
I love skeletons okay skeletons make
sense but what is it wood timber tanam
mouths how about these it's weird and
you start finding these things like
that's just factual psychological
process oh sure I have a yard full of
dead trees in the city comes by but Tim
Burton does it as art so trying to
figure out what to do with this I had a
suspicion that if if I went on YouTube
and tried to find every interview I
could of Tim Burton something told me
that he would just yep and that he would
just talk about his big thing yeah and
sure enough I watched I mean I thought
that's only that's a handful of clips I
watched a bunch more interviews but it I
mean there was it was right there he
talks about a clown doll the things you
see clowns skeletons be mocked and
laughed at being a loner being an
outsider even stuff that didn't make the
cut as I mentioned about the TV and
being labeled a weirdo it's all there
and so I was very glad that those
interviews were out there and existed
because it's sort of hammers home you
know I felt like we could say that like
we could just say that Tim Burton is
doing these things but it'd be so much
better if we could find actual him
saying those things so I was very happy
that in going through that that we were
able to find enough to make that run
because it's all right there yeah I just
love via the quickness of I love
skeletons of skeletons if yeah let's go
sometimes you find a sound clip and
you're like yes
that was one of them found him saying I
love skeletons I was like sweetie Todd
and that guy does the line of like we
keep the blonds in here to block
immediately like well that's gonna be in
the industry yeah do we keep the blunts
in here I was like oh thank you yeah I
love it and button hole where I'm trying
to think I thought there was another one
that didn't get included for some reason
but I don't I don't remember what it was
yeah we keep the blondes in here so
before you see his latest circus-themed
creation relive the films of a director
who gave birth to the big-screen bat
directed one of the most iconic comedies
of the 80s one of the strangest dramas
of the 90s helped keep the art of
stop-motion animation alive and also
make these movies but it's still best
remember for a film that he didn't even
direct yeah what's this what's this it's
not a Tim Burton movie that's for sure
it's so pause it's not it's not folks no
it's not nurses not a Tim Burton Henry
Henry Selick
yeah didn't write it either based on a
story right he produced it he had come
yes he came up with those characters and
I think he wrote a poem right like the
Disney days he wrote this out as like a
poem about Jack Skellington and that was
it that's all the Tim Burton actually
did on that movie but I have to be
honest going into it I kind of saw this
trailer going another way where and it
was an easier way of sort of coming in
and being like look at this weirdo and
this trees and his pen cough and Hot
Topic and everything and I have to be
honest it sounds weird but through
especially watching all those clips and
things and the interviews of him and him
talking like I am at like I'm obviously
we have to mention the bad ones that we
did the bad movies but my approach to it
completely changed because as I guys I
watched his movies first of all and saw
all these threads going through it and
then saw his interviews and the fact
that like he's not he's open about what
everything that he's doing and is just
like why we can't trash this guy not
because I want to hold back but because
like he's not pretending to be something
he's not none of it seems artificial or
like he's just trying to figure it out
the same as everyone else
oh so at this point like is there
anything really groundbreaking or
interesting about being like that point
of the Apes who he's pretty bad right
right Alice didn't mean it Alice we
didn't have her for Christmas we did
plenty the other thing I think even
though a lot of these newer ones are not
great and I don't like them very much
it's it's hard because he I'm sure if he
if studios would fund Edward
Scissorhands type movies from him he
would make them but that's not what
Warner Brothers wants to give him money
to do in 2019 like Disney's probably
only offering Alice 3 or Dumbo or like
one other options so like I don't know
if this is totally Tim Burton being like
I don't want to do old school Tim Burton
style movies anymore I just want to
reboot Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
were like that's what he's getting
offered to do what I'd be interested if
and you could literally only do it by
have sitting down and just like having a
conversation like an I like skeletons
kind of conversation but I'm curious if
like as you get older and you grow as a
person like all of those things that
molded you when you were younger like do
you start to feel artificial if you hang
on to them if they don't necessarily
apply to you anymore you know you've
grown as a man you found success like
you know it's for me it's like how many
more songs can like The Death Cab for
Cutie guy write about being lonely right
there one of your famous it is as a
longtime huge fan of Tim Burton it's a
little dispiriting that every time
there's a new Tim Burton movie it's like
well I'm rebooting this old cartoon or
I'm revisiting this old TV show but I
don't know how much of that you can
really lay it is feet versus that we're
in right now yeah there aren't scripts
like Edward Scissorhands or Beetlejuice
being sent to his office anymore I just
entered it kind of expecting to arrive
at a situation where we point out all
the stylistic things and we thrash galas
and Planet of the Apes
shadows because I had seen it yet new
you know it wasn't great and Charlie the
Chocolate Factory and talked about how
he would was this eighties icon but look
now it's making all this junk and the
actual truth of it was so much more
interesting to me then then let's just
crap I'm sure most of the comments would
be like I can't believe you guys just
didn't like just on Alice in
Wonderland for two minutes and it's like
we already did first of all for four
minutes movies they're just they're
boring it's not even that they're so bad
they're just like I'm not interested in
this there's nothing really much time
inai really there's nothing much to say
about that Alice in Wonderland movie
it's just a lot of visual noise and like
let's write over here now let's move
over here like it's not interesting
today
yeah I agree so you say sort of about
like is he just supposed to not work
because studios are just like we'd like
you to make a dark shadows movie or an
Alice in Wonderland because on one hand
you know you obviously it's up to the
artist it's interesting to see how like
similar people go you could be Tim
Burton who has you know paid his dues
and every now and then gets offered a
crap thing and it's like okay I'll make
the crap thing because this is my job
and I like to work or you know on the
other hand viola you have like a unit
Vasquez who you know did invader zim and
is like my way or the highway and like
I'm never gonna sell out and it's like I
respect it but definitely not working as
much as like a Tim Burton he to pull off
these kinds of movies these doing he
needs a budget he can't like he can do
big eyes for a low budget and make a
cool indie thing but you know if he
wants to make a movie on par with what
he's been doing he sort of has to have a
major studio behind him yeah I don't
know I just I I almost see filmmaking
for him as something that he has to do
not like for money but just because he
has all of this stuff inside of him that
he has to what cuz he's doing awesome
he does art too and here ie to me
melancholy death of oyster boy that book
of short stories like that's why I
wonder about a force that's why I wonder
about this sometimes in like the shift
in quality is it like Burton sort of has
hit
and I'm not making fun of poet I think
it's interesting to watch the journey of
an artist like yeah did he hit a
crossroad were like he had exercised
enough exercised enough of that stuff
and it's kind of like know what you know
and that's sort of where you get that
shift of like an Alice in Wonderland or
I don't know I don't know I don't know
we don't know let's keep going
I'll be storing paleface Johnny Depp
Lisa Marie Helena Bonham Carter yeah he
did do that super Ram that's the
intersection point so many people that's
another one yeah famously mm-hmm
never he was married once way before in
the early part of his career never got
married again had long-term
relationships with with several numbers
Lisa Marian how about Carly's but again
that's the kind of thing for those four
movies big fish corpse bride beetlejuice
Alice in Wonderland not nothing in
common but that's a we write and they
for writers these different writers but
I think it's thematic it's something
that that just like it seems like a
little bit more than coincidence it's
like this is just something you see
running even Bruce Wayne in in his
movies there's that fear commitment like
why won't you let me in you got in like
it's not a romantic sweet line it's a
very reluctant frustrated put-upon
line and you know him and Catwoman in
the second I mean the romantic language
him and Calhoun is a mistletoe could be
deadly if you eat it I guess can be even
deadlier if you mean it and then you'll
die in and then it sort of flips towards
the end of that movie where she's like
your fairy tales garbage and like yeah
well I'm jealous of murders Max Schreck
with a kiss yeah yeah concept of the
there this this fairytale wedding is
actually a nightmare Sweeney Todd those
song is out I mean yeah
and love is very dangerous and often
leads to misery at the end like Edward
Scissorhands - I mean it's it's very
down note after he falls in love yeah
fishes not necessarily a fear of
committing with relationship but that
movie is about a guy that can't stop he
keeps moving and chasing and and that
feels like a later later version where
there's still the thing of like because
that's a that's sort of about marrying
or almost marrying the wrong person
right as but it is ultimately a very
happy marriage and and and you know look
at the time and he was in that time in
his life he was in a very committed
long-term so it's just you just look at
different four phases of life yeah it's
just weird to see it's an interesting
one because he not only re-examine the
commitment stuff but like that whole
movie is reexamining his weird parent
stuff yeah - yeah did the dad and
reconciling with your parents with your
father
you could read I almost just wanted to
start writing a book yeah another thing
from him which is like tall tales and
stories and legends and myths and do you
really believe this or not and it's made
up you know which is another thing that
runs through all of it yeah yeah let's
keep going graveyards old gnarled trees
if the dragons if he just likes
designing and filming these things yes I
think that's a lot of it is like his
animators into my bones could I keep up
with my bothers tactile things right
buildings to have a present for you this
is a great run
there's so many more spinning left just
a style thing he just likes this imagery
there's actually there's two of them
from Sleepy haha I noticed the other
have to get because she spins around
there yeah there's also in the party
christina ricci Spencer yeah there's
there's a lot of spinning and we could
put all of them in but yeah spinning
yeah I do love that sequence of big fish
that guys so happy that is there the
Bears in carnivals scary faces a witch
[Music]
yes most towns of a certain size have a
wheelchair obviously and models every
Tim Burton movie eighteen movies and
this guy still only made one sequel
where's beetle to bigger fish bigger
eyes miss Peregrine's other home for
peculiar children alison wonderland - oh
they made that wasn't a good call burden
yeah well there we have it
those are all it's in burton movies
that's them that's every Tim Burton
movie
Halon let me ask you this yeah what's
your favorite Tim Burton movie oh good
question I think I would probably have
to go with Beetlejuice just because of
the age like it was such a pivotal movie
in my childhood it forming my sense of
humor and I love Michael Keaton as a kid
damn favorite might be pee-wee's big
adventure I love it was a big it was a
big movie for when I was growing eyes
and there's just so much there's so much
humor and that just that that
conversation between him and Francis he
has like the comic energy behind it just
just what Francis is trying to target is
like I love that story so it's so
underrated just as a comedy there's so
many great line deliveries in that movie
like there's comic performances in
peewee or just off the charts good like
Francis and particulars like yes in fact
without me none of this would have
happened to you right peewee yes like
that stuff is so good I think that is
underrated just as a pure comedy but I
do I also find big fish to be incredibly
moving that's that's probably my
favorite
that idea of just Billy Crudup scare
achter understanding his father at the
last and just the this the it's just a
very moving concept to me to to indulge
in this idea that when you were close to
death that that it is this wonderful
thing of everyone you know being there
and just I I find to be very moving I
feel like it hits Americana and a more I
don't know real I guess like legitimate
way that like maybe a Forrest Gump or
something like that that was more just
almost almost like a firework show yeah
America but this like big fish just does
it in such a just really you're like
real soulful way that I really like yeah
yeah I also would we just want to throw
it Ed Wood is also remarkably good so
good and like really different from the
other Tim Burton movies but still feels
like it's got that core mm-hmm and and
that Martin land out before mile every
watch because I haven't seen it at a
long time but when you and you said
Beale just sort of like formed your
sense of humor and stuff like that I
remember packed theater I wouldn't saw
Mars Attacks with a bunch of my high
school friends I was like the only one
laughing in that theater crowded
auditorium with people like what is this
yeah I was dying you know I had the
series I loved Mars Attacks when it was
me when I feel like nobody else I knew
was into it yeah with Natalie Portman as
the president with a mariachi band yeah
yeah no I don't think in retrospect I
don't think all the work I think it's a
great like huge amazing cast Burton does
a great job it looks terrific the script
is the script is not where the rest of
the movie is like the jokes aren't as
funny if the jokes were better it would
be a classic I love Tom Jones with the
wildlife and being a falconer is set up
to get to that was a look other than
just like Tom Jones with the new Falcon
I just remember don't don't run we're
your friends and but yeah it's not that
all the actors came to play like
Nicholson's doing that duel
I guess what they had funnier stuff to
say and do yeah because they're all
they're all great I like about the
performances like Pierce Brosnan is
really funny in it yeah it's a lot of
good performances I just the movies
material is a weird yeah it's a weird
one probably sleepy Hollow's number two
I love that I do love that number two
very gothic starring our own sweet
Casper Van Dien yes indeed any other
club do we have any oh yeah we've got
our titles in it yeah these are all of
Roberts yeah we just want to make sure
you saw because he's amazing it's so
good if there's Sleepy Hollow one we
really don't deserve you we don't this
was a nightmare before christmas one
that we didn't include just because you
know we talked about the movie but not
quite the see the beetlejuice makes his
grave yeah dig here play plan of the
apes nice when i worked on the water a
lot my executive had a copy of the
Beetlejuice sequel in his safe Wow Wow I
felt really just goes Hawaiian no wasn't
ghost wine yeah ok the multiple be a
little too concepts out there in the
world yeah those are all by the way
Robert doesn't like take elements and
just put things on top of them yeah all
that from which really I was like six
months after I worked here before I
found that out it really blew my mind
that there was a way to like pull in and
they know he's just figuring out how to
make it look right yeah he's bright it's
insane no idea I don't know he's crazy I
think with the Aquaman one he was like
he tricked at his water by using a smoke
factor side he did a tweet about how
it's actually a smoke effect that he
just made look like water
I make snarky comments about movies not
on that level
any closing Burton thoughts I think I've
exhausted him he's just a fascinating
person when we first came up with this I
was really trying to think of a way that
we could do a joke about how there's
always children's choirs on all of the
soundtracks but can't play the music so
yeah that's always like when I think of
Tim Burton in my head that's what I like
about
we didn't really get into Elfman either
cuz it's right cuz you can't play the
song yeah
although we did get today we didn't get
to use one of my favorite first-come a
number tracks and be names for a track
which is the Beatle juicy one that I
think was under the the trope the the
the psychology run is is a Danny Elfman
Eska tune and it's called Edie skeleton
and skeleton skeleton that's one of my
favorite track knock off title tracks
names ever ed skeleton boys that's our
show yeah well next week's honest
trailer is a fun one if you're gonna be
a wonder con in Anaheim this Friday
night I think it's 6:30 I can't we're
premiering next weeks at WonderCon so
check that out we're doing that we're
doing a movie fight it'll be a lot of
fun yeah what's our tease on this one
mm-hmm
I don't I'm gonna give it away if I come
up with something so I leave that to you
guys yeah there's so many parallel T's
as we could do I you shouldn't yeah yeah
yeah let's not do it let's nobody got
that yeah that's it yep see you guys
next week bye E
you
[Music]